[Applause]
robinson with the three
ginobili scola tony parker
yeah well they they kind of find a niche
for five minutes
oh robinson fouled making a three
off of out of bounds play a little brush
screen that time handoff again
robinson a deep three and that's why
he's amongst league leaders
in three-point shooting shot 45 getting
a lot of attention but jimmy butler
creates a little bit draggage for three
jay crowder underneath with a nice board
robinson again
and he's two for two from d minutes to
go here
in the first half of game two on the
drag screen
hero great ball movement that's the guy
that you want shooting at duncan
robinson
who shoots 45 percent from downtown
they're in it and it's competitive
duncan robinson
inside got it back little pitch and
catch that's a very popular action that
they
use butler on the assist
a lot of contact underneath robinson
left open
and that is lethal offense
[Music]
shot clock down to six robinson rising
up
man he is still hot that is rare though
one for seven as robert orri did
but again most the vast majority
assisted but he recognizes shoot we got
to get one off here
great job getting back square there is
news on kendrick nunn jared will have
that a little bit later but essentially
he is ready to play today if his number
is called and
starting just like he ended in game two
he had 30 and his team is down he has
the license to just let it fly and take
bad shots not doing that playing within
the offense
catch and shoot duncan robinson
and look at just robinson's movement
look how he's keeping space and then
boom as soon as you turn around and you
start watching
the defender the offensive player in the
post look what he does nba postseason
was a revelation here during the seeding
round had that 50-point game
but has not been nearly to that level
duncan
robinson sticking a three in the
era of the three-point shot they've done
it defensively by shutting down the
paint
they actually give up the most made
threes in the nba
as duncan robinson banks one up
since coming down to florida
[Applause]
43 he was under 30 prior to that there's
robinson
can't leave him open the two seed
toronto
trails boston two nothing in that
eastern semifinal
has a three drops for duncan robinson
second on bledsoe robinson may have
traveled
doesn't matter splash milwaukee number
one in fast break points yes they during
the regular season shot clock at two
robinson in the corner one of the best
three-point shooters in the nba
second year player duncan robinson
twisted and turned that in
yeah over his many years in the nba hero
iguodala thought three by williams kicks
it out
duncan robinson three good our hero is
also in
now for miami that's a beautiful pass
duncan robinson with that domineering
disposition
that you would expect to see so far
duncan robinson connects another
three-pointer for robinson
the five years previous to that
miami was eight games over 500 as
robinson hits another three
he's in with bledsoe middleton hill and
marvin williams
duncan robinson knocks down the three
from the right corner
[Music]
robinson tries again hits again duncan
robinson his sixth three-pointer
butler in transition back to the shooter
robinson got a great look
butler with another opportunity he'll
try it twice
and the second one falls rockets has
been
great for miami pushing tempo robinson
finally gets another one to go
and duncan robinson hits the three to
make it a six-point game
it doesn't matter where robinson is on
the floor he said he battled imposter
syndrome
imposter that's a shooter right there
he'd had a rough start in the game one
as duncan robinson knocks down the
three-pointer what you said though
i'm not wanting him on the line late in
the game though i'll tell you duncan
robertson two for two to start out of
bio the rebound
back out robinson robertson again
here in the first half of game two
duncan robinson
again robinson now four for five
from downtown he's got 12 points here in
the opening quarter
if you're tight you got to be
disciplined defensively extends
over extends the defense giving them a
wide open look and
robinson continues to knock down shots
early in this ball game
much about the product on the floor and
the players off at duncan robinson
dragach on the drive pulls back up top
robinson fires it three
puts it in duncan robinson with his
sixth three pointer of the game
again they don't have anything and just
watch
the sprint behind by robinson
his man to help on the roll duncan
robinson lines it up that's good
robinson continues the hot shooting six
three-pointers in game
two butler the rebound
[Applause]
duncan robinson steps into a three
that's good robinson from downtown and
the lead cut to 14.
you know this was a great comeback no
i'm going to sleep after the game i'm
not waiting
duncan hiro showing his versatility as
the primary ball handler
duncan robinson drills another robinson
has found the range
109 101. jackson has been one of their
calling cards all season they're one of
the best defensive teams in the league
and coach talked about needing
to pressure the basketball mall you see
their early switching
keeping bodies on bam and boston playing
without either smart or
walker so totally point guardless
duncan robinson connects robinson from
downtown
he's got 12 points in the first quarter
that's by canner but
hayward's got to get going he's too good
butler behind the back to crowder
crowder off the dribble
cannon doesn't go for that fake duncan
robinson corner three that's good
what an accomplishment 4-1
three-straight series they played
exceptionally well got a lot to be proud
of and
tremendous stories all throughout that
get an easy one
good read on that steal and good bucket
duncan robinson wastes no time five
duncan robinson the quick release nails
the three-pointer jalen brown was right
in his face
i think that's his fourth but brown goes
under against robinson
[Applause]
gets back and gets a fairly good contest
but that's a lot of space
williams up right into adebayo
duncan robinson finds some room gets off
the three that's good
duncan robinson from downtown the lead
is five
[ __ ] dolla back to butler adebayo
double team out robinson robinson for
three bang
duncan robinson from downtown and the
lead is
15. what a fourth quarter performance
from the miami heat
plays here in the second quarter and a
lead is up to 17.
duncan robinson and the heat needed that
one he needed that one
and again he's just
jumping over the smaller defenders as
robinson
hits a three off good ball movement
great minutes in the absence of
anthony davis and lebron james a great
job getting into the seams
and making another fine play duncan
robinson hits the three
he also thought there was contact one of
the greatest games
i've seen in the finals particularly for
a guy
who's on a team that is really really
as robinson makes a three you think
about two years out of high school
here he is in the nba finals duncan
robinson nails the three-pointer
and look how deep davis is going under
all these pick and rolls with jimmy
butler
duncan robinson gets a good look and
knocks down the three
his second three-pointer of the game the
heat back within three
butler's gonna have to shoot the ball
from three if they go that far
under pass to crowd or shot clock
winding down
duncan robinson hoist up the
three-pointer backs it in
oh duncan robinson from way downtown
seven times in the paint area he's going
to win that battle
duncan robinson butler grabs the rebound
and davis grabs his right leg he's
limping down the other end
duncan robinson lines it up that's a
three robinson
six on the shot clock jimmy butler
drives kicks it out robinson left wide
open
nails the three duncan robinson tyler
hero one-handed floater won't go
butler battling rebound duncan robinson
nails another three
adebayo duncan robinson again that's
good and the foul
duncan robinson from downtown
potentially 12 minutes from an nba
championship what do you say to the guys
going into this
next time just gotta focus on our
assignments and playing the game thank
you so much frank
butler guarded by morris
shot clock at four butler drives stops
up top robinson puts up a three
that's good that's good james
guarding jimmy butler as the lakers have
an early four point lead duncan robinson
that quick release session
knocks down the three crowder by the way
davis picked up that
last laker foul that's his first lakers
by three tyler hero
nice little fake duncan robinson has
some room again that's two three
pointers they're just two of six
from the field after that fantastic
performance in game five
got that three-pointer to go his third
three-pointer
and it's 84-57